on continue maintenant avec marc bédard
le président et fondateur de lyon
électrique bonsoir monsieur bédard
bonsoir messieurs fusion alors gros
investissements et grande annonce
aujourd'hui qui vous permet quoi est ce
qu'on peut dire ça va doubler tripler la
taille de lyon electric a fait ça nous
permet tellement de choses ça nous
permet d'avoir un contrôle complet sur
nos batteries quelle est la batterie
basse et c'est un des éléments les plus
importants sur le véhicule donc ça nous
permet une réduction de coûts dans le
futur ça nous permet de sécuriser nos
approvisionnements
ça nous permet beaucoup d'emplois
évidemment comme vous le mentionnez le
j'écoutais ce que vous disiez là au
québec pour les prochaines années
en fait c'est l'écosystème complet qui
est en train de se créer au québec et au
canada
ça c'était une pièce maîtresse cela dit
il ya encore une part d'importation qui
va rester les cellules notamment
qu'est-ce qu'ils doivent pas assez pour
qu'on puisse importer les cellules pour
compléter vraiment le travail et la
fabrication qui est à quasi 100 % au
canada
ça prend des gros investissements c'est
des milliards en investissement pour les
cellules donc nous du côté de lyon ça
fait pas partie de notre langue notre
plan d'affaires impatience et des
cellules qui devraient être vendus là à
la grandeur du marché nous on a jugé qu'
à partir du moment où l'on construit
notre module et ont construit le reste
de nos packs batteries ba ce moment là
le salon a un impact important sur nos
véhicules
les cellules dans tout l'écosystème
monsieur legault a mentionné aujourd'hui
et monsieur trudeau également mentionné
les deux ça va beaucoup d'intérêt assez
d'intégrer ce jusqu'à la dernière pièce
manquante lucky maintenant la cellule
donc avec la fabrication de l'extraction
de lithium la fabrication de ce côté là
vous avez là aujourd'hui on parle de 100
millions des gouvernements 80 85
millions supplémentaires vont venir de
est-ce que ça va venir de votre rentrée
prochaine en bourse
voyez exactement c'est ça donc l'entrée
en bourse est imminente
et c'est exactement ça puis le reste
quand même les 100 millions c'est tout
de même un prêt elle
comme vous disiez tantôt il ya une
partie qui est pardonnable donc qui est
un incitatif pour les 20 prochaines
années
justement quand vous disiez le garder le
siège à salles au québec qui est aussi
une question de capacité de production
et tout ça mais faut quand même
rembourser ces prêts le loup fait au fil
du temps fort en bourse est presque
l'essentiel des prêts il ya une partie
effectivement pardonnable où vous
n'auriez pas à rembourser si vous
respecter toutes les conditions est ce
que vous auriez préféré une prise de
participation de la part de l'état
plutôt que des prêts ou des subventions
c'est une
c'est une bonne question moi je vous
dirais que la formule actuelle je pense
que la gagnante pour la société
également se tient prêt en grande partie
le prêt devra être remboursé d'un autre
côté ça donne vraiment un coup de main
pour rétablir ça c'est pas facile
d'investir 185 millions dans une usine
de batteries à c'est un gros projet sait
5 gigawatts heure donc ça nous a permis
d'y aller vraiment avec une grande
capacité de production moi je veux dire
est que pense que la formule qui a été
trouvé c'est une belle formule c'est une
formule qui est qui et qui remplit
d'incitatifs également avec la portion
part d'un homme qu'on parlait mais qui
est très juste également je trouve pour
pour la société c'est la première fois
qu'une usine comme ce qui se fait au
canada donc c'est très innovateur je
pense je pense que la formule est là bas
on apprend aussi aujourd'hui quand en
europe que volkswagen va construire au
moins six grandes usines de fabrication
de batteries tesla fait des grandes
grandes usines également comment comment
vous faites face à cette concurrence là
des grands fabricants du monde vous
regardez ces fabricants de là c'est
principalement pour des voitures et ça
c'est autre chose on atteste la qui dit
qu'il va se lancer mon année au niveau
dieu du camion donc de la compétition
moi je fais le très bien par rapport à
ça parce qu'un bon c'est bon parce que
c'est l'électrification des transports
qui s'en vient mais chevillon ça fait
quand même dix ans qu'on est investi
dans l'électrification des transports on
est extrêmement avancé et l'on pense
qu'en contrôlant tous ses aspects du
pack batteries parce qu'on parle de
coups de partout mais on parle aussi
d'approvisionnement en batteries dans
les prochaines années il qu'ils
pourraient 2
certains défis également quand on amène
ses packs batteries là sur des véhicules
où il faut les intégrer de façon
harmonieuse sur les véhicules et la
forme
ce pack batterie énormément énormément
d'importance donc c'est pour ça que
c'est très très important de faire ça je
suis pas du tout surpris de l'annnonce
de bronze ryan aujourd'hui je pense que
tesla va aller encore plus vite et pour
nous ce n'est qu'un début
j'ai très très contente de faire un
nouvel investissement quand on va encore
passer la barre des 14000 véhicules
qu'on peut qu'on peut qu'on peut nourrir
ou avec ses ici c'est ses batteries là
on s'est dit très content d'aller une
étape supplémentaire et vous avez dit
que l'entrée en bourse est imminente
est-ce que vous pouvez être plus précis
que c'est encore vous souvenez quand on
avait quand on a fait la première
production le 30 novembre
on avait dit que l'objectif c'était
terminé donc l'entrée en bourse le pour
la fin du premier trimestre qui est dans
deux semaines alors ça serait un axe
aller dans les deux prochaines semaines
mais ça va ça devrait arriver dans les
quelques semaines qui vont suivre
très bien merci monsieur bédard merci
beaucoup bonne chance pour la suite
celui ci
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit